dino concrete
ma li benvenuti solita storia oggi
nuovissima sala non dovremo scegliere la
porta sbagliata non c'e la parte
sbagliata in ogni porto si nasconde o il
passaggio per procedere o oppure si
nasconde un cattivo di quelli che
conosciamo di morelli di weibo resto
battute che tutti conoscete sarà super
divertente vincerò io ho vincerà vitale
lasciate un bel mi piace perché per
questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace ci sarà una seconda falsi non sei
nella porta sbagliata mettetevi comodi
preti concorrente caso quello che fate
allora dobbiamo scegliere o la porta
numero uno la porta numero due la porta
numero 3 quasi un cambio vero durava da
evitare come sapeva bene cosa votare il
cagnolino ha detto che porta dovrei
scegliere non lo so allora sappiamo già
che nella ii vitale è morto già perché
proviamo con l'a 3 dove
loro ok andiamo del lavoro
per un pelo penso perché la 3 non si
apriva ma l'importante che siamo
riusciti andare avanti vediamo questa
stessa aspetta qua dai sembra
facilmente finisce volo facilmente
bisogna stare super attenti a saltare
deve sottostare vitale assolutamente
dopo via
per chi fate il tipo per vitale
ovviamente
arancione ottimo si sono rosa e rosso
diciamo
rosa rosso
ecco un altro cagnolino dice dobbiamo
scegliere una di queste tre porte ma qua
non ci sono i numeri
come certo
andare in questa patria non ci vediamo
più scappano suo tempo era giusta
succede
viaggio
dentro appreso andiamo di qua vediamo
questa
speriamo che sia quella giusta
provare
ed io ho scelto la posta la porta giusta
ma dove stai andando
prima che mi ha spronato
sul buon giorgio per te che non stai
attento vie per forza questa siamo
qui
hide and seek stiamo giocando a
nascondino congressi e premi
non mi aspettavo di trovare così tante
credi che cercano una spia sicar cicala
batta se si vaio giallo sono sulla
turchia mornasco dino no grazie grande
così brutta con l'aiuto ricky sono in
vantaggio ecco le altre tre porte
altre porte di
ok io provo la 1 devo ricominciare una
vita e
non alla 1 va bene allora io andro nella
ii io andrò nella 29 davanti
nella iii media chi è questo è un mostro
che possono c'era quello scrivetelo nei
commenti non lo conosco
non ho preso una bomba ma perché mi ha
affiancato un altro personaggio
qual è la forza giusta si stanno
continuando a uscire dei personaggi
cattivi
attenzione quindi che cosa ti è successo
prima e niente praticamente stavo qui
che stavo andando bene tra quello tra
quello no poi all'improvviso fatto poi
strozzarla del 1800
ma anche tu però
[Musica]
vorrei che stare qua per evitare che
dirà se la quale sarà la porta giusta
adesso massima sicurezza c'è scritto e
il cane dice non sono un criminale siamo
in una prigione se dobbiamo stare io qua
sto bene vediamo proviamo questi sono
altre porte quindi dobbiamo scegliere
tra sono sentito va beh io provo con
questa e vediamo che cosa se qua dentro
tutti
ma io sono passato
da karen
provo questa porta
indovinate chi è in quanto tali bastardo
bigharp il pareggio de vincenzi in bar
ancione cosa assisterà in questa porta
non un cattivo ma li
ho fatto andando malissimo perché tutti
noi questa sarà la porta giusta vediamo
come si chiama marzo come si chiama
ma ho provato quasi tutte le porte
quelli devo andare allora in questa sera
karen proviamo questa centrale
[Musica]
non è molto facile di qua vitale in
vantaggio sì sto parlando le burt allora
tv passare prima che passino gli altri
giocatori altrimenti crolla al ponte
[Musica]
quante
portabile l'aspetta perché ogni porta di
porteno ti porta ogni porta vi portano
un posto diverso il cane dice sono molto
confuso
proviamo andare di qua e di là c'è un
punto esclamativo qua si fa sempre più
interessante queste skyroom sì ho
trovato la porta giusta
no come hai fatto
no aspetta questa volta mi ha portato
nell'altro corridoio da voluto metterla
giù amicale e donne via superare già e
dove no sono tornata all'inizio mi ha
spronato
speriamo che evitare continui a
sfracellarsi così possa raggiungerlo è
molto difficile quello che c'è dopo è te
lo dico è un labirinto praticamente si
riusciva a lui eccovi dare la giusta
aggiungiamo lo sono qui ciao
treno che non ti sei sfracellato 10
milioni di volte astratto lì come mai
che cos'è questo bisogno di ascoltare e
non chiedi baldi si adesso per
diffusione attenta perché si muove nevi
devi correre
no si muove sono infatti tantissimo se
ne va tantissimo nichi
dove siamo queste cose siamo in una cosa
ci sono varie poste qua il cane dice
tutto ho lasciato la chiave di questa
porta dovrebbe essere qua vicino io mi
sono seduto qui a fare il
momento
chiave
dove la seco io così almeno possa
vincere io la trovo
una cassaforte che sono se si vuole la
chiave anche qua non si apre obama forse
la dobbiamo scassinare proviamo
quest'altra porta acqua o forse nascosto
proprio come la chiave non ti prego
vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua dentro ho
trovato un inizio
che brutto brutto pure io adesso la
chiave tanto quarati sfracelli rai
adoro questi frutti super divertente
queste porte sembrano familiari perché
sono tratte forse da un videogioco che
conosciamo perché montella mi sa di sì
forse ho capito
o altro rapporto di fi mezzo si vede che
proviamo la porta centrale
ma ha
sbagliato di nuovo
allora è per forza questo arrivando sto
passando in mezzo alle ruote
è riuscito da giusta è bellissimo perché
paura
arrivare
da zucchero che hai copiato ora aperto
per i appena passata due no perché come
ho fatto er del fuoco parteci sfracella
lotta di un preso fuoco molto facilmente
stai bisogna passare da un'altra parte
no
ok riproviamo fortemente la gara e
velocissimo uno alla volta
come team a portare qua ma forse sia
un'altra entrata proviamo a
tale riuscito a passare come fai il
velocissimo vero si sbriciolava l'ultimo
proviamo
velocissimi via
questa è davvero la parte più difficile
di tutta l'escape room
c'è mai fatta se riuscite a
zero se n'è fatta ce l'ho fatta non ci
fate il tifo per evitare lasciate un mi
piace su vitale e per portargli fortuna
lasciatemi piacere
dai nas su mi piace qui sotto è adesso
vitale ce la farà lo vuoi bene ne sono
sicuro
senza
un senato il voto su gaza vediamo cosa
dice cagnolino ora dobbiamo entrare in
uno di questi ascensori
sono io
che ti vediamo
cosa succede
che succede
non capisco
sono intrappolata dentro ha fatto pare
sì o no anche tu
aiutatemi ad uscire per una donna
intrappolata dentro un ascensore è un 1
è uno dei miei incubi
abbiamo scelto tutte e due le porte
sbagliata ok ho dovuto fare azzera
personaggio eccomi qua ok allora non era
quello centrale proviamo questo
vi diamo
è quello giusto
credo di no
allora io provo quello centrale e basta
non ero il primo nemmeno quello centrale
allora qual è ho un'idea proviamo è
malvagio e vitale ma proviamo senza
premere quel pulsante bianco
vediamo infatti io sono rimasto bloccato
nel porto sul pulsante bianco però non
succede niente lo stesso ok ragazzi
abbiamo ricominciato da capo perché si
era beccato difensori non funzionavano
ma fortunato proprio funzionare vediamo
provavo guardi così
bigicchi
questo che blender me
il pagliaccio
fai rat
karen
il jeff
capitale
oggi
[Musica]
ci sono i laser che che si aspettano
chiaro
con calma
non farti affettare ci provo
i
trasporti aveva definito ci siamo quasi
e io scelgo questa riesce tutto questo
ha aiutato me sono ha scelto la porta
giusta io ho scelto la porta giusta che
così si reca le skin room vista
dall'alto
dice che abbiamo finito con un time
quindi in 7 minuti e 3 secondi
lava tre minuti in meno di merce wow
e qua nel podio ci sono quelli che hanno
finito le skifo room più velocemente
vuoi dire wow e ora dice di buttarci
quaggiù
sopra di lei
sa
[Musica]
che è successo al vetro scuro
quest'altro so che questi sono i pochi
giganti se volete che lo troviamo
l'estate un bel mi piace nota 10 mila mi
piace lo proveremo è stata troppo
divertente è pronta ora vi lasciamo 4
casellina da cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video il caso quella che
preferite